I would like to introduce my two
teammates and also the creators of the
wish granter cow Atanasoff and john
mcdonald I really believe that they were
just as much responsible for this film
and they should be up here sharing this
award with me well I I'd like to thank
my parents and they've been dying to
hear me say that forever okay but I
really mean it and I love you guys and
you support me so much and I also want
to thank my brother in my aunt patty and
uncle Frank who are here in the audience
so thank you guys this is for my mom and
dad they've always pushed me to be the
best that I possibly can they've never
given up on me
and I am what I am because of them today
thank you so much
so I think it's obligated that I also
thank my parents thank you mom and dad
Thank You Evan they've always been there
to support me and it's been a rough
journey and they know that and I just
want them to know that we made it so
first and foremost I want to thank Paul
downs he is a teacher and advisor a
therapist and he is most importantly our
friend and he was there with us making
sure that we had the guidance that we
needed to finish this film and then I
was also like to thank at Gavin who is
also our senior faculty advisor he was a
great guy and he was nice enough to tell
us that we didn't stink even though we
didn't bathe for four or five days at a
time and then also I would like to share
this award with the two other ringling
films that were also nominated as
finalists for the animation award the
last shot and the controller this is for
you guys no way to represent Ringling
yeah so I've heard so many ridiculous
things said to me throughout my my
career and the most ridiculous thing
that's ever been said to me is that you
can't make your passion become a future
and I am standing here today and I want
you guys to know that that is not true I
you know we just all worked so hard to
make sure that this was such a memorable
thing and make sure that we were able to
make the best film that we were able to
make and make it here and we didn't
think three years ago that when we all
met that we wouldn't even be accepting
something so tremendous on behalf of
just everyone who has supported us so
thank you guys and thank you to everyone
at Ringling who's helped us grow and to
also help kick our ass into place is he
they've definitely done a really good
job making sure that our film we knew
that our film needed more work when it
did so yeah we would love that much so
my message to you guys would be to
always pursue your dreams make sure that
you are responsible and you know that
you can believe in your
and everything that you do is possible
creativity is one of the purest forms
imagination and it should not ever be
forgotten so thank you guys